it's a small table yeah it stays a small
tone show the people are good people
here the delivery service people depend
on it
you know they miss it when it's not
there to me a car is something that just
really needs to be dependable for my job
it's my choice whatever vehicle I wanna
drive drive a junker or nice Tesla
I try not to go down the road that oh
yeah I'm driving a really cool car it's
not personal personality where Lada
reliability is number one they deliver
properly with it there's no capacity in
it I can put a lot of mail in there my
route is around 124 miles probably about
80 of those miles of gravel roads
I have 38,000 miles on it now and royal
maintenance I have to do is basically
keep it clean the dust and stuff it
beats the color up a lot but this seems
to handle it better
I've had many different cars and most
days it'd be around 2530 dollars a day
in fuel expense then I started looking
at this and he's like well I can't run
anything for 3 bucks a day you know can
be snowing out or raining out roads
muddier people depend on me to show up
and deliver their mail my name is Henry
Nelson and I deliver mail with a Tesla